where do you live
with Colossus owner and spoon why the
mask ugly are the jokes insecure my
Princess Bride I'm a fan
why Celine Dion I'm a bigger fan my the
holidays thought it'd be fun my pg-13
it's a family movie also money also
Disney why do you think audiences will
be stupid enough to swallow this not
sure this level of curiosity is cute
coming from middle-aged man strapped to
a bed against his will one on timing not
on your [ __ ] life right before
Christmas a good guy in red he's coming
to theaters with his new sidekick
Fred why am I here so I could read you
the story of Deadpool to filtered
through the prison of childlike
innocence you'd say for grandma's I love
your working up and approve four teams
for the first time ever
Deadpool's pg-13 the only f-bomb were
using around here is Fred Savage once
upon a Deadpool rated pg-13
everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Deadpool Fred savageness to
break down I love the way he's ripping
into Deadpool they're using you this is
a really good opportunity to call
Deadpool on a lot of his bullcrap they
also directly call out the Fox Disney
deal why are you doing this because I
thought it'd be fun also because money
also because Disney so we'll do a new
brand of the giveaway for IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite joke from the trailer on the
video there's a couple of their funny
clips that they've dropped from this
that I'll work in later in the video
there were a couple of jokes that they
were actually paying off in this from
the Deadpool 2 movie that they set up
there was this really weird line of
comedy that they went down between the
Deadpool and the Colossus characters
where every time he would go back into
the realm of death to talk to Vanessa
she would make some funny Colossus joke
[ __ ] Elvis
Dolf a colossus he has somewhere he
lives he says he lives with Colossus
that's a reference to that like oh he's
living with Colossus now you could also
say that after the events of this movie
he was trying to become part of the
x-men and maybe because Colossus had
accepted his philosophy like sometimes
you do have to do bad things in order to
be a good person that maybe they would
allow him to live at the x-mansion on a
very limited basis but because Vanessa
is supposed to be alive now I think that
he would be living with her but then
they double down to the Colossus joke
when he asked do you own or rent and he
replies with spooning like spooning
Colossus so they're really going for but
then they go from being more joke
answers to being a little more literal
and on the nose why do you wear the mask
because I'm ugly pretty straight up
that's why they did the Hugh Jackman
mask joke at the end of the first
deadpool movie because you won't love me
i'm so hideous so i'm gonna make myself
look like this beautiful Hugh Jackman
person deadpool loves The Princess Bride
movie he says he's an even bigger fan of
Celine Dion
now that's Ryan Reynolds like they
wanted to do a very Bond type opening
song so that's why they chose Celine
Dion but I'm sure in real life Ryan
Reynolds does like Celine Dion a little
bit but in the comics Deadpool tends to
be inspired by whichever pop musician or
rock musician fits the tone of whatever
story he's telling like whatever's
really popular like he's been inspired
by Freddie Mercury before by ac/dc he
sings in quotes from a lot of lyrics in
all of his comic books so he tends to
reference a very wide range of popular
musicians but the funnier fourth-wall
break is when it's really Ryan Reynolds
speaking to us the audience on a real
subtle level like why are you doing this
because I thought it'd be fun it's a
family movie also money also Disney sort
of backdoored confirming that even
though yes the original idea for this
was to do something that everybody could
go see like they wanted a family movie
because a lot of them have young kids
that can't go see the r-rated version of
Deadpool that because Disney is who they
are like Disney is Disney they just make
a certain type of content that they
wanted to test the waters to see what
would happen if they did a pg-13
Deadpool movie to prove to Disney hey we
can do this character within the box of
content that you allow people to make
like very rarely would you ever see the
chance of an r-rated Marvel film even
though Kevin Feige says that they've
thought about it there's just not a
really long list of r-rated movies the
Disney is chomping at the bit to make
Deadpool would be the exception
because it's been all rated this whole
time but if they're ever gonna put him
in an Avengers movie which it sounds
like they plan on doing down the road
they've just had to bring him into more
of the tone of what the Marvel movies
are even though on a very basic level
you don't have to change anything about
what the character does instead of
making fun of all the x-men like he does
in the Deadpool movies he'd just be
making fun of the Avengers characters
there's a clip of Deadpool trying to
stop him short before he drops an f-bomb
this is probably after he first wakes up
in the bed he probably knocks it out
captures him ties him to the bed then
wakes him up then you get that f-bomb
moment they also just dropped another
promo where Julianne Denison fire fist
takes some shots at infinity war as you
would expect them to do upon a time
there was a Kiwi Superstock with
Julianne Tennyson the star of detour to
2018 s best superhero film nobody died
at the end of them as much as everybody
loved it Paul - though Ryan Reynolds
obsession with swear words and violence
made that kid some of the sixteen
including myself weren't allowed to see
it forced to wait and watch it on DVD
like a loser will just miss out
altogether
not cool man not cool but Santa heard
the cries of the children and delivered
a prison once upon a Deadpool an M rated
version of Depot - that the whole family
could enjoy it had more than 20 minutes
of new footage new jokes and most
importantly
me the true spirit of Christmas nobody
died at the end of that one
I would just expect the level of
Deadpool MCU references to rise
exponentially after this Fox deal goes
through even though they have a little
ways to go before they start making the
next Deadpool movie I hope that they use
him for some promos next year because of
all the Fox Disney stuff like not
necessarily a promo for his movie but
just use Ryan Reynolds to sort of shine
a light on what's going on like remember
the scene during Deadpool 2 where he's
walking around the x-mansion in
Professor X's chair when he starts
breaking everything when he puts the
cerebro helmet on just cut a promo with
Ryan Reynolds doing stuff like that with
MCU characters inside the Avengers
facility just making a joke about how
he's in the MCU now if he didn't see it
either there's obviously a lot of
Wolverine stuff going on in the
background every time Ryan Reynolds
talks about Deadpool he also talks about
Hugh Jackman and trying to get him to
come back the surprise new announcement
that Hugh Jackman made last week that
everybody was curious about ended up
being a solo tour that he's going on
unfortunately as expected it has nothing
to do with Marvel or coming back to be
the character or anything like that
right now it just seems like based on
what he said Hugh Jackman will only come
back for very brief cameos of Wolverine
stuff and then maybe only on a limited
basis indefinitely not in the very near
term future so like if he does do a
Deadpool 3 cameo that we won't find out
about it till late next year the actual
movie once upon a Deadpool is coming out
next week I think I'm allowed to post my
review on Wednesday so I'll try to
figure out what the schedule for that's
gonna be like Julianne Denison said in
that promo there'll be more than 20
minutes of new footage so I will do an
Easter Egg video new post-credit scenes
anything that they attach to it I
haven't seen the movie yet but I'll be
seeing it in the next couple of days
most of that new 20 minutes of footage
that fire fist mentions is probably a
combination of the Fred Savage scenes
with him just ripping into Deadpool and
calling him on all his crap or alternate
takes that we didn't see during the
movie or during the SuperDuper cut that
they released on home video where he's
making the up joke about the old woman
potentially dying don't get too attached
there were actually a number of deleted
post-credit scenes like a couple of
alternate x-force scenes with like an
alternate team at the end of the movie
that they said that they dropped so who
knows if they'll ever work that into any
of the releases but because of what
they're doing with the prints
this bride and cutting out some of the
more WTF graphic stuff I'm hoping that
they altered some of the post-credits
scenes as well so maybe we'll get a new
post credit scene speaking of which
there's also a whole bunch of venom
blu-ray deleted scenes and post credits
and all that stuff dropping next week so
I will be doing videos for that but
obviously that all be separate stuff so
we'll remind everybody about all the
reviews posting next week because I also
think I'm allowed to post my
non-spoilery Aquaman review next week
too don't forget we have an Avengers 4
trailer coming up and a spider-man far
from home trailer just the beginning
though there's other Marvel stuff
happening so while you wait for
everything click here for that new
spider-man far from home teaser and
click here for that brand new Captain
Marvel trailer thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]